esta vez nos preguntan cuál parece ser
el valor del límite cuando extiende a 7
deje de equis y bueno aquí tenemos
replicado la función bien igual a gdx
así que pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
encontrar la opción correcta ok ahora
pensemos en lo que está pasando si
observas por aquí tenemos a esta función
que está definida en x igual a 7 pero no
es continua con el resto de la función
así que algo interesante está pasando en
x igual a 7 si observamos la función si
está definida en x igual a 7 y de hecho
toman el valor de 3 así que déjame
notarlo
gm de 7 toma el valor de 3 ok esto es lo
que vale g de 7 pero estoy seguro que
alguna vez estuviste tentado a todos nos
ha pasado en decir hey este límite es
bastante fácil es simplemente lo que
vale la función pero de hecho este es un
buen ejemplo
para mostrar la diferencia de que
algunas veces el límite existe y se
aproxima a un valor que es diferente a
lo que realmente vale la función en ese
punto así que pensemos un poco en el
límite si nos fijamos en valores más
pequeños que 7 y nos acercamos al 7 por
la izquierda observa nos estamos
acercando al 7 por la izquierda entonces
cuando tomamos valores más pequeños que
7 lo que está pasando es que nos
aproximamos a este valor de aquí déjame
ponerlo con este color para que sea más
obvio ok y si ahora nos fijamos en el
límite por la derecha es decir nos
fijamos en valores de x que sean más
grandes que 7 entonces nos vamos
acercando nos vamos acercando nos vamos
acercando y nos acercamos de nuevo al
mismo valor así que parece que nos
estamos aproximando al mismo sitio sin
importar si nos acercamos por valores
más grandes o más pequeños que 7
y es por ello que podemos suponer que
este límite existe ya que en ambos lados
nos aproximamos al mismo valor aunque en
este caso el valor es diferente al valor
actual de la función recuerda el valor
de la función es 3 pero aquí parece que
el límite cuando nos acercamos a 7 toma
el valor de parece ser de 0 así que
veamos nuestras opciones y si observas
la primera opción es 0 así que de hasta
de lujo esta sería nuestra respuesta
correcta pero de todas maneras vamos a
ver las demás opciones para estar
completamente seguros y verificar
nuestra respuesta después sigue el 7 que
es una opción de hecho este es un
distractor porque buscamos el límite
cuando x tiende a 7 y nos fijamos en x
igual a 7 todo el tiempo pero esto es
algo que se aproxima x queremos saber
cuánto vale la función mientras nos
aproximamos a x igual a 7 así que en
definitiva esta no es la opción correcta
déjame quitarla no es la opción correcta
porque es a lo que queremos aproximar a
x y después sigue esta opción que es 3
bueno esta es una opción interesante
porque de hecho este es el valor que
toma la función en ese punto recuerdas
que de 7 es igual a 3 observa tenemos
una función que es discontinua en ese
punto y justo aquí tomamos el valor de 3
entonces déjame escribirlo esto es
realmente lo que vale
de 7 ok y por lo tanto no es la opción
correcta porque yo lo que buscaba era el
límite y lo voy a tachar muy bien y por
último tengo que el límite no existe lo
cual tampoco es cierto porque como ya
vimos el límite cuando x tiende a 7 de
esta función que de x es igual a 0
entonces tachamos también están y ya
tenemos la respuesta correcta